Can you help me interpret this?
Looks like some good news, bad news from retesting.
So when you guys look at your CT scans and stuff,
whether you're trying to figure out if it's getting better
or getting worse on a CT scan, I think you're in the right.
Well, you're okay. So this is, let's look right here.
So this says this area is talking about this first, this first mass.
Okay, here's this size.
And it measured this size before.
So this is better. It's gotten smaller.
Here's this second mass. It's this size now.
And it was this size before.
So it's gotten smaller. So that's good.
And then you go, this one is this size now previously measured this.
So this is where it gets a little sketchy because of the previous measurement didn't give you a three dimensional measurement.
And, and like we referred to like somebody talked about at the last Zoom call,
is that if you don't get it done at the same place read by the same radiologist,
there's a lot of subjective interpretation of these things.
And different CT scans give you different objective determination.
So just because this is gold standard, doesn't that mean it isn't really anything close to gold standard.
So, which you're really looking for in re-scans, like you could say,
you could say, oh, yeah, look at it. It's gotten smaller.
Whoo, that's fantastic. Well, yeah, but you're within a range of error here.
And not to burst your bubble that it's, you know, hasn't gotten smaller.
Well, that's great. But you're still within a range of error here.
Really, what you're looking for when you do a reskin, you don't want it to go.
You know, double in size or something like this one down here.
Measure this, well, it measured this before. Well, that's gotten bigger.
Still within the range of error, you're talking about four millimeters here.
So in this, in this one, looks like it's, this one's, okay, this one's stable.
So you're really looking for, if it was this size before, 4.7 by 4.4 by 3.7.
And it's now 7.7 by 6.4. You know, it's gotten considerably bigger.
Anything within, you know, five millimeters. It's just, it's just, you're way within the range of error.
So if this was me, and this was my cancer, I would be very happy with the way I'm going right now.
You know, you laid it down that you don't want to try to do things or try different things.
I certainly wouldn't scuttle my, you know, like crude protocol. I think you're certainly putting the break something's here.
So it's not growing. Remember, we talked about, if your cancer's not, you know, actively growing.
You know, that's good news. It's not acting like a cancer right now.
You've got to keep it that way, but this is very good news or a course here.